He's my brother. His name is Samuel and
he's been invited by his Muslim friend.
He has two question to ask.
>> Okay brother.
>> Okay. The very first one is not even a
question but I would like you in one
minute
to convince me to convert into Islam
and then one minute just ask one
question. My brother's first question is
he wants to be convinced convinced that
to be a Muslim
>> in one minute
>> in one minute.
Is that correct? He wants to be
convinced to be a Muslim in one minute.
That's the first question.
>> And then another question in regards to
what's happening in Palestine and Israel
at the moment.
Do we both believe in the same God or is
there different gods for
>> I can't understand.
>> You cannot understand.
>> Can the brother repeat? been saying
in regards to what's happening in
Palestine and in Israel at the moment.
My question is
are there different gods
for
>> are there different gods?
>> Yeah, are there different gods? That's
what I'm asking and that's what I would
like to understand. Is there one god for
both of us or are there different gods
or like what what are we supposed to
believe in? Can we not just coexist and
stay together as one?
Is that not possible?
My brother's second question is
regarding what's happening in Palestine
and Israel
>> and Israel. Is there any other gods
handling these issues?
>> Is there any other
>> other gods?
>> Any other gods
>> handling this issue? So what is he
supposed to believe in?
>> Okay, brother has asked two questions.
The microphone is not very clear. So
that's the reason maybe we cannot
understand the accent of the brother.
The other brother is more articulate so
I can understand that also not very
clearly. There are two questions asked
by our non-Muslim friend. You said your
name was Samuel. Samuel
sorry name is Samuel.
>> Yes correct. Samuel.
>> Samuel. Samuel has asked two question.
Can you convince me in one minute
regarding Islam? Brother I gave a talk
for two hours. Did you find anything
wrong in it?
>> Okay. If there is one thing I really
admire about Islam is the unity and the
togetherness that you guys have. I
really like that so much about Islam and
the honesty about you know I have so
many friends who are Muslims who work
together. We share so many things
together and they are very honest people
comparison to other people that I meet.
So I just want to be convinced maybe in
two minutes or less to become a Muslim
and then I'm also asking if maybe gods
are different for Christians and
Muslims.
>> Can't understand.
>> Yeah that's what I want. Okay brother
can you repeat? Okay. I'm saying
>> now can the brother behind repeat?
>> He's saying he just needs to be
convinced in 2 minutes in short period
of time.
>> Sorry.
>> He wants to be convinced.
>> Wants to be convinced
>> in 2 minutes time.
>> Convinced about what?
>> About Islam. He has so many Muslim
friends but they share a lot of things
at office. So he just needs to be
convinced in 2 minutes time about Islam.
>> Brother, do you believe there is one
God?
Yeah, I believe in one God.
>> Do you believe Jesus is God or a
messenger of God?
>> Okay. Another thing is
>> No. Do you believe Jesus is God or
messenger of God?
>> Just a minute. Another thing is
>> I'm asking you a question within just a
minute.
>> No, I'm answering you with a question
and I'm saying
I'm a born Christian but I'm not a
religious person. So I want you to
convince me. Yeah.
He is born in a Christian family. He
wants to be convinced about Islam.
>> That's what I'm asking him. I'm asking
you. You believe there's one God. Very
good. Do you believe Jesus is God or a
messenger of God?
>> Is Jesus God?
>> I don't know about religion. So maybe
you tell me because I'm
>> No, you don't believe Jesus is God.
>> I don't believe in Okay. I am a born
Christian, but I'm not
>> I know you said you're a born Christian.
I'm asking you, do you believe Jesus is
God or a messenger of God?
>> I believe in only one God.
>> I can't understand.
>> He believes in only one God.
>> Mashallah. Very good. Do you believe
that Prophet Muhammad is the messenger
of God?
>> I believe in both Muhammad and Jesus
at the same time.
>> Can you repeat, brother?
>> I'm saying.
>> No, no. Can he repeat the person on the
right?
>> Believe in Muhammad and Jesus at the
same time. He's saying he believes in
Muhammad and Jesus at the same time.
>> Mashallah. Very good. You have to
believe better. There are two important
things to be convincing regarding Islam.
Number one, believe that there is one
God which you already do. We have to
believe that Jesus is a messenger of
God. And we also have to believe that
Prophet Muhammad is the last and final
messenger. So all these three things you
believe these are the minimum two
factors. There is one God and prophet
Muhammad is the messenger to you to
enter the fold of Islam. Minimum two
things. Other things can come slowly.
For example, when you take admission
into a school, first you have to take
admission then you learn more about it.
So the minimum two criteria for any
human being to enter the religion of
Islam is to believe there is one God
which you already do and to believe that
prophet Muhammad is a messenger which
you already do. So according to me
you're a Muslim.
Correct. Now regarding your question
about Palestine and come to it then I
come to your first question again.
Regarding Palestine, we know for more
than one year and two and a half months,
Israel is attacking Palestine, attacking
Gaza. And in the last more than 14
months,
there are more than 45,000 Palestinians
who have been killed.
That's the noted number. The actual
number will be multiple times more.
There are more than 100,000 who have
been injured. actual number will be
more.
You asking me which God correct? Where
is God? Allah subhanana wa ta'ala says
they planned and plotted Allah to plan.
Allah is the best of planner. Now some
people ask me cannot your God make the
people of Gaza win? Yes, they can. Very
easy. But if suppose on the 7th of
October 2023, if God the next day would
have made the people of Palestine win,
the misconception would yet continue.
There's a misconception amongst most of
the non-Muslims all over the world, more
than billions of non-Muslims. They think
that Israel is right and Palestine is
wrong. Now after 7th October 2023, there
was a live telecast of the genocide.
Never in the history before has there
been a live telecast of genocide. All
the genocide done earlier we come to
know after few weeks after few months
after few years here non-Muslim are
watching. What kind of religion are
these Palestinians following the mother
the son is being killed and she's saying
I would not mind sacrificing even if I
had five more children.
The children are being killed and they
are saying alhamdulillah praise be to
Allah. The people who are losing their
house
they have become homeless instead of
complaining to God they're praising God.
So the non-Muslims all over the world
whether in America in Europe and western
countries they are thinking what kind of
a faith is this? Even with so much
trouble yet they're praising God yet
they're thanking God. they started
reading the Quran. So there are hundreds
of thousands of non-Muslims in the
western world in America in Europe and
other parts of the world they have
accepted Islam.
So when they see this live on the social
media they started reading the Quran.
When they read the Quran they realize
that this book is something different.
It's not like a so this is Allah's plan.
Allah is purposely letting them do
atrocities. Now if a Palestinian dies,
he'll go to Jenna,
he is martyed, so he gets the reward.
Nowhere does it say that. And the people
who are creating the atrocities, Allah
will punish them. At the same time,
millions of people all over the world,
including yourself. When you watch, you
start having a soft corner for the
people of Gaza.
They are breaking all the rules. They
are breaking all the international laws.
They are targeting women. They're
targeting children. They're targeting
schools. They're targeting hospitals.
The world has come to know that the
Israel people and American are the most
unjust
including the American government which
has funded more than $17 billion to
Israel to kill tens of thousands of
human beings, innocent human being. So
now the world has come out in support of
Palestine. Is this better? Or if Allah
makes them win, the world yet will have
a soft corner for Israel. So this is
Allah's plan. Allah says
they planned and plotted Allah to plan.
Allah is the best of planner. So do you
realize the hikmma the wisdom of Allah
of God?
>> Okay. Uh I have another question to ask.
uh maybe you can clarify on this.
Okay. Another question to ask is
uh I really would like to understand
what jihadism means and how relevant it
is to Islamic religious religion I mean
sorry and uh suppose that maybe right
now today I convert into Islam. Where do
my Christian friends stand? Are they my
enemies or are we fighting each other?
>> Can you please repeat the question?
>> Just leave the mic. Just tell me the
question.
>> My question is
>> can the brother can the brother repeat.
>> There is a difference.
>> Don't ask it alone. I want to ask myself
I I don't understand why you can't you
can't hear what I'm saying.
What I'm asking is this sir. I want to
understand what jihadism means and how
relevant it is to Islamic religion. And
then suppose maybe today, right now,
right here, I convert into Islam. Where
do my Christian friends stand? Are we
supposed to be in a conflict or are we
supposed to be fighting each other or
are we supposed to be coexisting or
something of that sort?
>> Can the brother behind repeat? Yes.
>> My brother Samuel is asking he wants to
know the explanation of jihad. Correct.
Any other thing? where my Christian
friends stand.
>> Where do Christians stand? And he's
asking suppose he becomes a Muslim
today. Where does
>> where do my Christian friends stand?
>> Where does his Christian friends stands?
>> Are we enemies? Do we become
>> Does he become enemy with his Christian
friends?
>> Very good question. Regarding the
concept of jihad, I discussed yesterday
that jihad does not mean any war fought
by any Muslim for any reason. Jihad
means to strive and struggle.
If I'm striving and struggling to make
you explain Islam, I'm doing jihad. If
you are striving and struggling to
understand Islam, you're doing jihad. So
jihad basically means to strive and
struggle. You asked me the question that
if you accept Islam now, where do your
Christian friends stand? Once you accept
Islam, you have to convey the message of
Islam to them. Because you cannot be
selfish. You cannot be selfish that I
came to know the truth. Now I will not
share the truth with my friends. If your
Christian friends are there, it becomes
your duty that you should love them
more.
love them more and convey to them the
message of Islam because they are your
friends otherwise on the day of judgment
they will complain to almighty god they
Samuel he got the truth did not share
the truth with us so once you become a
Muslim it becomes your duty to share the
truth with others so the moment you
become a Muslim you have to convey the
message even to your non-Muslim friends
to your Christian friends and call them
closer to Islam
so would you like to accept Islam. You
said you believed in one God.
>> You You believe that Prophet Muhammad is
a messenger of God?
>> Yes, I do.
>> You believe Jesus is the messenger of
God?
>> I do.
>> So, would you like to say it in Arabic?
>> I would like to learn maybe.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. You would like to say it in Arabic?
>> Okay, I'll say it and you can repeat it.
>> Au
Allah.
illudd
>> I bear witness
>> that
>> there is no god
>> but Allah
>> but Allah And I bear witness
>> And I bear witness
>> that Prophet Muhammad
>> peace be upon him
>> is the messenger
>> and servant of Allah
>> and
>> servant of Allah.
>> Okay. Servant of Allah.
>> Mashallah. You have become a Muslim. I
would like to congratulate you and I
welcome you to the fold of Islam.
>> As the prophet said, the moment you
accept Islam, all your previous sins are
forgiven. All your good deeds you have
done remain and I pray to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala to give you the best
in this world and the and may you convey
this message to your family members and
to your friends.
>> Okay. Thank you very much. May Allah
reward you.
Clean.